The summit between the leaders of North and South Korea
ended on Sunday.
That's pretty compelling to watch that go down.
A lot of people felt we'd never see
this happen.
Right.
And one of the most striking images was this shot
of North Korea's Kim Jong-un arriving at the summit
with body guards running along side his limousine.
I don't know if you saw this.
This was absolutely.
(laughing)
Absolutely blew my mind when they showed up.
Yeah, and everyone was just blown away by that. (claps)
Now that seems like a lot of security.
I know.
But if you're in the public eye trust me you cannot be
too careful.
In fact true story Warner Brothers gave me my own security
detail.
(laughing)
Don't giggle it's necessary.
I'm an iconic figure in America.
(laughing)
Billy let's show the footage of me coming back from lunch
today at the commissary.
(laughs)
Okay, that's me.
(clapping)
Coming back
from the commissary.
(cheering)
Then I realized I forgot to get ketchup packets
at the commissary.
So I'm headed back and then a fan tried to get a selfie.
But we took care of him.
(laughing)
This is the way you have to.
(cheering and clapping)
You started to lose
them at the end.
I know trust me.
You're accelerating.
We had to get that
in one take.(laughs)
(laughing)
The director was like should we do it again.
I'm like I don't think we should do it again.
(laughing)
Gertrude can't handle that.